this is a story from
the past year it involves cheating
wiretapping
multiple state court cases gpsing police
involvement and parental alienation
all right so it just it's about uh one
year and change but
um it'll give you a little bit of frame
of what what
can happen to some guys this isn't a
benchmark for all guys but just
understand
this happens it is more
it's more common than you think let's
let's just put it that way
december 26 uh 2016 my wife of 16 years
had an affair and was convicted
and sorry with a convicted felon in my
bedroom
with children under the age of five in
the bedroom so
dude's married to a chick for 16 years
she has an affair with a convicted felon
with children under the age of five in
the bedroom while they're going to pound
town
okay so uh fast forward a few years
december 2019 after enough trying and
lies i asked my wife to visit her
parents
in uh i guess that's new hampshire from
texas where we're living to hopefully
gain some perspective and maybe try
again
i don't know you know what guys are
glutton for punishment they always want
to try again
wife of 16 years is porking a convicted
felon in your bed with your children
in the the room but that's
that's what men like to do complicate
their lives and justify why they do it
right
how many times have i said that february
2020 she files for divorce in texas
february 2020 she files for protective
order in texas
false accusations of abuse she follows a
protective order in new hampshire for
falls actually
accusations of abuse she files i don't
know what a cps report is in texas and
i'm investigated drug tested and deemed
innocent
i'm guessing that's child protective
services she follows another report in
new hampshire where i'm investigated
drug tested and deemed innocent
she files child support taste case in
texas
uh this is all in the course of like
four months here
so she's basically doing every she's
throwing everything she can at this guy
she cheats on him
with a felon with his children in the
bedroom
and she's going jumping through all
these hoops to make his life miserable
i procure an attorney in new hampshire
to fight the dv restraining order that's
domestic violence
we asked for continuance prep denied new
hampshire protective order hearing one
times one telephone here in new
hampshire rules no access to chil
so he loses access to his kids in april
of 2020
orders me to forfeit my pets and my
protective order is granted
may of that year so a month later i pay
five grand down and get an appellate
attorney notice of appeal filed in new
hampshire
okay you're speaking american legal
terms that i'm not familiar with but
january sir june 2020 requests a
father's day call with children the
night dude doesn't even get to talk to
his kids on
father's day july 2020 supreme court
brief filed the new hampshire's 40 grand
for that
he pays five grand here at this time so
he's at 45 grand here
evidence of extensive wiretapping
discovered of all my attorneys
privileged calls over eight months
apparently that's how they knew
what to say in new hampshire
who's who's wiretapping this guy's wife
wow judge orders me to pay 5700 a month
in child support terminating my ability
to afford term
attorneys my diversity and i cover this
in my book on why smart men don't get
married
i break down the math of of of the the
scam that is child support
um november 2020 my diverse attorney
calls
sorry quits because i can't afford her
evidence of
gps location and listening device found
in my car
wow this trick's going through
everything eh
without any well you know she's porking
convicted felon so maybe she was
you know getting down with the guy that
was into this stuff evidence of gps uh
without an attorney
x's attorneys destroyed my ability to
fight for my kids and she's granted the
house the car
all my belongings three thousand dollars
a month in support on top of fifty seven
hundred dollars a month in
uh child support so he's paying her i
guess alimony
and i'm barred all access to the kids
with no access to his kids
see this is the thing that drives me
absolutely bonkers
about freaking family law
and and marriage they're all like yeah
just go get married just go do it
you know what could possibly go wrong
you know go and
go and pass on your seed liberty blah
and then
16 years into a marriage a dude's wife
could be
banging a convicted felon in your bed
with your children in the bedroom
and then she goes through all of these
hoops to manipulate the
legal system to alienate him from his
children so he can't see them
he's paying fifty seven hundred dollars
a month in child support plus
uh three thousand dollars a month i'm
assuming in alimony maintenance support
whatever that's called
in that state and uh
this is this is only uh november of that
year
so four years after he found out his
wife was uh
up to shenanigans he's going through all
this nonsense
with an attorney she uses my suicide
note to procure an arrest warrant in new
hampshire against me
you know a lot of guys will consider
taking
a permanent uh step to a temporary
problem in their lives and you got
just be careful with that guys i mean
you know talk to friends and family just
[ __ ] call into my show do what you
got to do but don't
don't go doing something like that over
uh over what family law does
it'll pass i promise you as [ __ ] as it
might seem
if you're in it right now or if you're
or if you know a guy that's going
through
divorce honestly dudes just reach out to
him send him a text
you know if you see him just say hey man
how's things going just wanted to check
in on you
right because that's what men do anyway
she hires a private investigator to
locate him
she files to renew new hampshire's
restraining order and is granted without
due process she procures the police to
contact my work to locate me
anyway it cuts off after that he
basically stops but
you get the idea it is anyway i figured
uh
that'll be a opening segway
to tonight's show it doesn't really have
anything to do with the topic but i
wanted to get that out of the way
because the guy had
an interesting time learned there
you